well this is such a cute story does your
child or maybe someone you know want to
play
college golf well two local sisters do
and they're sharing some key insight on
how to make dreams a reality for
students in their new book check this
out
my name is angelina huang i'm 14 years
old i'm cameron huang and i'm 13 years
old we wrote a book together it's called
i want to play college golf it's about
14
golfers and one sports psychologist
journeys
and experiences how they grew up to be
successful
through the golf journey and we also got
their advice
we were inspired because when we were
younger
starting off at golf besides our coach
we didn't have a lot of guidance
so we created this book to help
other golfers starting on their journey
to succeed and have
a better golf experience the competition
for junior golfers who want to go to
college is pretty competitive
everyone has the same swing and like
perfect form but it's about
how to separate yourself from the rest
of the field in addition you can also
expect to read about
15 personalized journeys of the people
who we
interviewed in the book the person who
works harder than everyone else and
sticks with whatever they're doing
and really knows their own game masters
what they do and becomes a better player
said meeks
there's really no secret out there
without giving away the full story of
for example our coach eric meeks
he's a person we interviewed in the book
he won the u.s
amateur and he got to play in
professional events such as the masters
about last year in 2020 we had the idea
to create this book
and after planning out who we're going
to interview
we started writing the book around
october and we finished
in march writing the book with my sister
was very fun we got to share
some some stories together
and it was just an overall fun
experience and created
a better bond between us golf is
deceptively simple and endlessly
complicated
it satisfies the soul and frustrates the
intellect
it is at the same time rewarding and
maddening and is without a doubt the
greatest game mankind has ever invented
arnold palmer after reading this book we
want junior golfers to walk away with
the right mentality and mindset in order
to pursue their golf journey to play
college golf or succeed
being an author at 13 years old is
really exciting and
we hope to see where the book takes us
it just recently came out and you can
find it on amazon
and just search up i want to play
college off and it'll show up there and
you can buy it from there
let's learn what it takes to play
college golf together
they're so cute so for more information
about that book or to buy a copy go to
iwanttoplaycollege.com also on amazon as
the ladies mentioned
thank you to significance dental
specialists for sponsoring
that segment what impressive young
ladies those are two to definitely watch